what do you do when you're in an
all-time low in your business I'm going
to share my thoughts in today's edition
of ice cap so recent got a question for
one of my YouTube subscribers love you
guys tochi who wrote in the say hey Evan
thanks for all the videos glad you're
feeling and poachy I have a question
that I hope you can answer during your
next radio show or something I have an
idea for a website about a job
marketplace the problem is getting
capital to go ahead and also the
motivation to keep striving right now
I'm at an all-time low seems like
nothing is working how do we you can get
the drive even if I do get the website
running I still have no idea how job
boards Craig revenues for investors to
get interested I hope you will reply
soon thanks tochi so tochi first of all
know that it's totally normal to to get
down on yourself every now and then
something that every entrepreneur goes
through there'll be days when you doubt
yourself to be days when you feel
totally worthless I went through this
every entrepreneur goes to this we don't
talk about it but it's normal that
happens so know that you're not alone to
help you with this I'll give you three
suggestions that I think might get you
out of your hole number one is do
something that you love it's hard enough
to start a business it's so hard to
start a business nobody talks so how
hard it is to start a business that if
you are not doing something that you
absolutely love there's no way you're
going to stick with it so many people
start a business just trying to make
money by the scene opportunity that make
lots of quick cash here and and they
don't stick with it because it gets too
hard and the thing that keeps you going
through it is you just love it it's
something you would do even if you were
not getting paid to do it that's a test
would you do this even if there was no
way to ever make money doing it and I
feel like from reading your message that
you don't really love what you're doing
here you I don't feel a passion for job
board you don't really know how they
work you don't know how to make money
doing it you don't have any passion
motivation you don't even started this
thing yet you really don't have any
motivation and I feel like if you
wouldn't do something else do something
that you really love something that
really helps bring you a lot that helps
fuel the energy and the excitement and
the power
to help you get to that next step and
keep putting effort in so number one is
you got to do something you love and I
really feel like you're not doing
something you love right now number two
is start with what you have right so
many entrepreneurs complain that I don't
have the resources i don't have the
partner i don't have the connections I
don't have the money i don't have XYZ
right you fill in the blank here's what
I don't have to be successful welcome to
the world of entrepreneurship the
conditions are never perfect to start a
business you will never have enough
resources to help you get to where you
need to be and the key thing that
separates the entrepreneurs that make it
from the ones that don't is you start
with what you have instead of thinking
about what you don't have you think
about what you can do with what you do
have and so it's never been easier to
start a business it's never cost less
it's never been easier to set up and and
and start getting some traction for your
business and again if you love what you
do you find a way start being
resourceful stop looking at what you
don't have think about what you do have
right now and how you can apply that to
make this business grow and number three
is model success anytime I'm trying to
do something that I'm really excited
about and interested in I love doctor to
number one right do what you love then
my default is thinking about who can i
mom who's done this before who can I
look up to who has a track record of
success who's 12 through what I'm going
through right now who can I model and
apply their strategies to learn from
because there are two ways to do things
one is to try to figure everything out
on your own right try to be the genius
trying to answer every single question
ever all on your own and usually that
leads to failure over you can say hey
I'm not the first person to try to do
this and find people who've already done
and understand what work for them apply
those strategies to your business and
help you grow and it works not just for
entrepreneurship but anything that you
want to do want to be a better
snowboarder you're going to be a better
husband or wife you want to be a better
father you want to be a better salsa
dancer you can model success on people
who are doing it extremely well learn
what works with them and apply those
strategies
to your life and your business Soto
chair hope that helps I'm feeling the
despair and the the sadness in your your
message and I hope this helps kind of
bring you up when you are doing
something that you are passionate what
in love I'm telling you it makes the
biggest difference in the world and will
give you the energy that you need to
keep going so I hope those tips help
continue to believe thank you for
watching and for everybody who is
watching I love to know how you came out
of your biggest depression how you came
out of that situation where everything
is against you and you're at the bottom
and you don't know how to rise up maybe
you're there right now and you're
suffering through it how did you get out
of there what's your plan to get out of
it I'd love to know your story sharing
the comments below and I think it could
also serve as inspiration for other
people who are going through that right
now